(sign squeaking)
- You can't trust nobody these days. SMH.
- Oh man.
- You're supposed to be my friend.
- Okay.
- You know what you look
like with that beard
a little league coach.
- I know you're not
talking about my beard.
- Yeah, I'm talking about you.
Look at you trying to be
smart with those glasses.
- What?
- And blue's a terrible color on you.
Drinking coffee, like an idiot.
- I don't even know what I did to you.
- You know exactly what you did to me.
- Is this about the time I
roasted him in front of Pamela?
(laughing)
I just roasted you in front of Pamela.
- No, this is not about the time
you roasted me in front of Pamela.
- Then what is this about?
- Don't play dumb.
- I'm not. I'm just honestly,
I just don't know what
you're talking about.
- Why don't you come over to me
and confront me like a man.
- All right, fine.
- Look man, I'm sorry.
- Oh just one sec, Zach.
I'm finishing up something here.
- Ok, I see what you're doing
but I'm here face to face talking to you.
- I'm sorry, I don't know what
you're talking about Zach.
Okay, but just one sec.
- Okay, that's it.
Uh, I'm going to just go
and take me and my
little league beard here
and just go home here because
you're being ridiculous.
Stop being so immature man.
- What?
- All right, I'm sorry.
You can stop subtweeting at me now.
- Thank you, Brent. All
I wanted was an apology.
(upbeat music)
- Actually, I do coach little league.
It's called Brent's Bombay Bombers.
We play on Sunday if you want to stop by.